i feel like there's a lot of fake
wokeness for sure a lot of [ __ ] a lot of
predatory um
you know people were doing a lot of
posting and a lot of [ __ ] just for to
make themselves feel good for sure it
was very trendy absolutely nah that's
100 all day um but
you obviously ended up getting arrested
i think my son was there yeah yeah was
trey there uh yeah yep trade of truth
yeah absolutely
what is your take on that man because i
do feel like
we see it now right like there's hell of
[ __ ] that's still going on in the world
and but it's not as trendy
as it was because it's not as trendy for
sure you'll see like a lot of artists
like that like you were like oh or a lot
of people in the for that matter like
what like like what is your thought on
that like you know because as somebody
who like really sacrificed their freedom
yeah to you know push against injustice
um
you know does it kind of make you feel a
certain type of way when you when you
kind of notice it's like there's a lot
of [ __ ] going on too you know at
first i did because again this is
something i've been doing since i was
like a a kid and you know i'm far from
an activist i don't have all the answers
i'm not perfect right um
but
i was going to you know philando castile
um protest as a kid mike brown and as a
teenager on my own free will
and um the only difference now is i
actually have a platform
and i actually got a felony from getting
arrested that day like i just got that
removed like off my i couldn't even like
travel overseas or anything because i
had a felony
yeah yeah i couldn't and so i just got
it removed thank god
and um
so i say all that to say at first i used
to get mad because i see a lot of people
just doing it because it's trendy and
you know but i was like you know
especially artists you know um what what
was the term
that i used for it was um
i
i forgot the term i had for but i can't
remember off the top of the head
but um
i can't i forgot the term i can't
remember any who but um at first i used
to get real mad at like you know all the
fake actors activism the fake walkness
whatever especially from entertainers
and things that nature because i know
they're doing it for their own internal
benefits so that people can be like oh
yeah you're a real one you really but
then i thought about it even if they
intentions aren't pure and coming from a
real and pure place at least they are
getting the message out there the people
that need to see it bringing more eyes
to the that's it even if you know like
even if you're the biggest person on the
planet
and you don't really believe in the
cause and you're just doing it from an
impure place well at least you're you're
showcasing
um the the problems that we got going on
in the world in general to your platform
to where people may be educated on it
want to do something about it so i don't
get mad at it honestly no more i used to
and
you know it's a james baldwin quote to
be black in america and just somewhat um
aware of what's going on is to be
enraged all the time
and
and i try to stay aware of everything
but i try not to let everything get me
super enraged if that makes sense
if you really like if you really pay
attention to everything that you're
going to be mad all the time it's going
to penetrate your peace nah it is for
sure and it does like it's hard
especially
it's again survivors remorse as in even
you know with just my immediate circle
but just with the whole
community as a whole you know you want
to
do everything and give as much as you
can possibly to everybody but
it may not even be possible you know